[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
soixante dix huit pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sociétés chaque mois nous
nous penchons sur l'actualité à travers
un documentaire thématique aujourd'hui
cybersécurité ac piratage broutage
internet et ses pièges avant d'évoquer
le document qui va suivre je vous
présente déjà les deux invités
d'aujourd'hui aurélie segonne morand
bonjour est avocate auprès du cabinet
elle aime ses partenaires avocats sur
mon cinéma automne eux et puis également
plateau aviez vos sacs
bonjour le chef des opérations pour la
société s'il reste qu et j'ai réussi à
le prononcer correctement cité la
reprise on parle donc d'internet
aujourd'hui la sphère facebook lé l'a
prouvé nos données ne sont pas en
sécurité on rappelle que le géant et en
pleine affaire du cambridge analytica et
du nom de cette société britannique
accusé d'avoir récupérer illégalement
les données personnelles de quelques 50
millions d'utilisateurs de ce réseau
social
mais au-delà de cette affaire les pièges
sont nombreux sur la toile des
techniques de piratage à l'abus de
confiance comment se protéger nous en
parlerons à tout à l'heure pour le
moment où vous allez à découvrir
l'envers du décor du broutage le
principe est simple ce sont des
internautes ce la plupart du temps
africains qui se font passer pour des
européens par des courriels sur les chat
ou sur les réseaux sociaux et qui
séduisent des européens en mal d'amour
jusqu'à leur soutirer de l'argent
direction à la côte d'ivoire pour vivre
riche de joël akaffou une co production
tv 78
dix mille fois oui c'est bien comme ça
vous appelez des copies la police après
son gain tout est là pour nous il n'est
pas au bout des trajets moselle a mis sa
médina sera pas finie c'est à nous à
découvrir sur lui maintenant de savoir
mais d'origine toujours est moins
évident et mouiller des mines etc
thierry est pas rien se sont brûlés
alain enfants n'ont pas d'ipad et hugo
sarah touche
ce matin quitte à parler du sommet
si ça va se passer
at il dit
me fait chier
de retour sur le plateau de tv soixante
dix huit pour 7,8 société consacré
largement à la cybersécurité et plus
particulièrement aux pièges d'internet à
l'importance de rester vigilants et de
protéger ses données 1 re bonjour donc à
nos deux invités
aurélie segonne morand vous est avocate
et xavier beau ça que vous avez le chef
des opérations pour une société
justement sur internet s'il reste qu
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
dans le documentaire qu'on vient de
découvrir il est question de broutage
alors j'aimerais déjà qu'on redéfinisse
de quoi il s'agit précisément c'est une
arnaque
pour faire simple un petit peu aux
sentiments exactement il s'agit
d'utiliser pour une personne
malveillante des données qu'elle va
récupérer en vue de la séduire parfois
d'utiliser un sentiment amoureux donc
d'utiliser une situation de faiblesse
pour nouer une relation et in fine et
obtenir de l'argent de sa part par des
transferts de fonds alors bien souvent
avec la coopération de ça peut être de
services de police ça peut être des
services de la poste il peut y avoir des
intermédiaires à cet effet et bien
souvent en effet la personne en
situation de faiblesse va mettre
énormément de temps à se rendre compte
de la situation
c'est un abus de confiance mais
savais tu laisses vigilance en fait tout
simplement aussi peut-être des
utilisateurs oui ça peut être un manque
de vigilance tout à fait ça peut être
effectivement une situation où là où la
personne est vraiment en manque d'amour
très clairement et qui va donc tomber
dans le piège relativement simplement et
qui aura du mal à s'en défaire puisqu'il
va y avoir un sentiment de honte qu'elle
va développer si par exemple elle a
divulgué des photos nues des loups bien
des vidéos compromettantes et parfois
même evans va même pas passé le cap
d'envisager une procédure au déposé une
plainte pénale
alors pour quand les possible de déposer
ensuite une plainte oui tout à fait
c'est peine perdue alors il est tout à
fait possible de déposer une plainte
pénale en naturellement qui donnera lieu
à une enquête des services de police qui
peut être relativement poussée la
problématique réside dans la
circonstance que il faut pouvoir
identifier l'auteur
donc s'ils sont malins évidemment ça
rend la chose complexe par ailleurs
l'hébergeur du site peut se trouver dans
un pays où il n'ya pas de coopération
avec la france par exemple permettant la
facilité des poursuites donc c'est vrai
que dans un certain nombre de cas il est
impossible finalement d'arriver à mettre
la main sur l'auteur identifié
ça veut pas dire que quand on est
victime il faut se résigner non
certainement parce qu'ici c'est tout de
même un premier pas peut-être même vers
l'acceptation aussi serait-ce que ça
exactement sachant que encore une fois
beaucoup de personnes
finalement se refuse à vouloir mettre la
problématique entre guillemets sur la
scène publique et refuse de donner
encore davantage de publicité à une
situation dont elles sont vraiment honte
ayant communiqué une vidéo par exemple
infos compromettantes exactement
compromettantes sa vie beaussac votre
entreprise se donne pour mission d'aider
à adapter la politique de sécurité afin
d'anticiper les risques de piratage de
protéger aussi les systèmes
d'information ça c'est pour les grandes
lignes de votre mission
votre travail au quotidien dans un cas
comme celui-ci vous pouvez pas faire
grand chose finalement non exactement
on peut pas se protéger de ça si ce
n'est
aujourd'hui d'avoir une une hygiène
informatique d'avoir été sensibilisés à
différents à auzat à la remarque
justement au ressentiment donc c'est
pour ça que c'est important de diffuser
ce genre d'émission pour qu'un maximum
de personnes se rendent compte
qu'effectivement ils peuvent être des
proies lors d'une faiblesse
psychologique lors d'une recherche
amoureuse assez facile avec ce qu'ils
vont mettre sur internet sur les réseaux
sociaux puisque c'est d'aider des proies
qu'on va aller chercher sur les sites
des rencontres effectivement sur les
réseaux sociaux faut savoir que les
brouteurs s'échange où se vendent les
fichiers entre eux et également lorsque
vous êtes tombés en fait avec un dans
une arnaque et ben milot en profiter
pour continuer et s'échanger les bonnes
pratiques entre eux voilà
donc effectivement c'est vraiment de
l'éducation c'est de expliqué qu'il ya
pas deux je vais prendre un exemple
assez concret
un iphone x à 1 euro c'est pas possible
voilà donc ça paraît ça paraît simple
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes mais le
principe c'est vraiment de dire
méfiez-vous
il ya toujours quelque chose derrière
voilà alors on est sûr de l'abus de
confiance y aussi d'autres techniques 1
pour récupérer les données sur internet
chose à une petite parenthèse tout à
l'heure en début d'émission j'ai voté la
situation de facebook que vous inspire
cette situation de ce vol de données
justement second cambridge analytica
alors c'est un gros sujet puisque ça
rejoint en fait un sujet aujourd'hui qui
est leur gp dès qu'ils rentrent en
vigueur au 25 mai au 25 mai 2010huit
frères gpb pour les initiales c'est
règlement général sur la protection des
données qui doivent compléter ce qui
existe depuis 1978 il n'avait pas trop
bouger qui est une évolution
effectivement on allait de 2,60 18
modifiée en 2004
donc effectivement on a une évolution on
a effectivement aujourd'hui l'europe qui
se dote de moyens pour protéger la vie
privée des citoyens européens
et donc effectivement on voit avec
l'actualité que c'est très important et
qu'il est il va falloir mettre cela en
place relativement rapidement mais l'un
des premiers moyens de se protéger c'est
également aussi des minimiser les
données qu'on va distribuer sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'on va distribuer à
diverses structures pour éviter
justement qu'on puisse s'en servir
faut voir que ce qui se passe dans ce
pour 7 pour cette structure
on est juste en train de dire
qu'aujourd'hui le break site qui est
passé à moins de 2% a pu être influencé
justement par cette société via un
recours sur le vol de données
oui bien sûr puisque les vols en tant
que telle est répréhensible donc il
s'agit d'une infraction donc il ya moyen
de déposer une plainte pénale
naturellement ou de faire une citation
directe directement devant le tribunal
correctionnel
si l'infraction est d'ores et déjà
caractérisée et si les données ont été
volées un hébergeur justement parlé de
facebook par exemple qui se fait voler
ces données on peut se retourner contre
cette entreprise également tout à fait
alors après il faut pouvoir identifier
l'hébergeur un bras ya des moyens
techniques pour le faire et puis il ya
des procédures d'urgence qui permettent
d'obtenir en fait les coordonnées de
l'hébergeur sur autorisation du juge
il ya une adaptation aussi de la
profession d'avocat j'imagine de la
justice à toutes ces nouvelles
technologies parce que forcément on
déposait pas le même genre de plainte et
il ya encore une dizaine d'années tout à
fait déjà dans notre métier
que ce soit le métier d'avocat ou le
métier de magistrat nous avons une
évolution déjà depuis un certain nombre
d'années puisque tous nos échanges avec
les juridictions sont numérisés
dorénavant quasiment donc il ya
nécessairement une adaptation est par
ailleurs effectivement il ya un volume
de plaintes sur ce type de thématique du
type les fraudes au président du type
les escroqueries à la carte bancaire
mais qui se font par les réseaux
internet ou bien les escroqueries compte
paypal ou encore sur le pap enfin tous
les sites que vous pouvez utiliser le
bon coin qui effectivement se
multiplient donc les services de police
sont également sensibilisés avec des
services de cybercriminalité qui se
développent et quels sont les arnaques
les plus fréquentes sont internet
les escroqueries à la carte bleue
l'escroquerie sur des virements en fait
qu'ils sont effectués ou les gens en
fait reçoivent un mail non identifiés
vont faire vont commettre l'erreur en
fait de l'ouvrir vont rapidement tomber
dans le piège et effectuer un virement
et la problématique sécu en la matière
ça va très très vite
puisque quand le virement et aux péris
quand bien même une plainte pénale est
déposée en fait les fonds peuvent
quitter le pays en moins de 24 heures et
donc faire déjà navigué à travers deux
ou trois pays avant qu'ils soient
identifiés et donc pour les services de
police il faut être très réactif ce qui
peut être compliqué on va revenir sur la
question d'hygiène informatique mais
tout d'abord il serait ce que les
coordonnées bancaires il faut jamais les
maîtres alors sur destituer les achats
en ligne
du coup ils ont que il faut pas les
éviter puisque on rentre dans un monde
où les achats en ligne sont quasiment
automatique et systématique maintenant
mais disons qu'il faut utiliser des
sites sécurisés et naturellement
effectivement utilisé un guide des
bonnes pratiques d'hygiène informatique
tout simplement avoir des réflexes en
faisant attention langage utilisé dans
les mails par exemple la syntaxe des
phrases bien évidemment jamais ouvrir
des mails ou des pieds joints que l'on
ne connaît pas bon après c'est sur un
plan technique mais il ya des réflexes
de base en fait qu'il va falloir adopter
au fur et à mesure pour éviter de tomber
dans ce genre d'arnaqué de pièges c'est
le message que vous faites un peu passé
chacun dans votre corps de métiers de
l'hygiène informatique qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut y mettre derrière
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire au
quotidien
mais ce qu'on peut lui faire des jeux au
quotidien aujourd'hui vous avez donc
lundi que l'autorité de référence 1
au niveau français qui est
a mis en place ce qu'on appelle ses
climats académie qui est une réussite de
plateforme pour se sensibiliser soi même
c'est à dire que soit on a la chance
effectivement aujourd'hui d'avoir une
entreprise qui a pris conscience et il
s'en suivit ses salariés soit on n'a pas
encore cette chance là et on peut le
faire soi même
voilà ce site là existe ça existe il ya
quatre modules qui permettent de
sensibiliser à l'ensemble des risques
quand on va là qu'on va pouvoir avoir il
ya également un guide des bonnes
pratiques a été identique a été mise en
place sur lequel effectivement on va
vous indiquer qu'il faut changer ces
mots de passe régulièrement faut avoir
des mots de passe forts alors je sais
bien que c'est la plupart des gens dit
bah oui mais comment on fait parce que
j'utilise x mot de passe dans ma journée
sur x ce site donc j'avais un carnet
pour tous référencés alors ordinateur on
prend le risque
voilà son sein les des post it et
actuellement il ya plein de voix
notamment des reportages on voit des ça
dans les écrans
les postillons bien vous re pourra
excéder donc en fait on peut éviter des
choses comme ça avec des ce qu'on
appelle des gestionnaire de mots de
passe il suffit à vous deux pour vous de
retenir un mot de passe fort à ce qu'on
appelle une master key
et en fait le site le ce logiciel va
vous permettre en fait de générer des
mots de passe avec les niveaux de
sécurité que vous aurez besoin en
fonction des sites parce que le niveau
de sécurité n'est pas identique en
fonction des sites sur lesquels vous
allez aller et qui va retenir pour vous
en fait ces deux mots tu sais même pas
ce qui fait que si vous faites à qui est
ce qui arrivera de toute façon
malheureusement vous n'aurez qu'un mot
de passe à modifier et ça n'aura pas
d'incidence en fait sur tout le reste
vous dit si vous faites à quai et quoi
qu'il arrive ça arrivera the wii je vais
le même principe que tout le monde est
exposé malheureusement aujourd'hui que
ce soit dans la vie privée où que ce
soit dans la vie professionnelle de
toute façon on est malheureusement on le
voit tous les jours
on se fait avec nous on a des
dispositifs effectivement qui nous
permettent de voir sur certaines
sociétés les tentatives de piratage au
jour le jour
elles sont multiples et malheureusement
les données
parce que nous on a été bon on n'a pas
fait exprès mais on a laissé entre
guillemets des mais on est on n'a pas
été vigilant sur les données qu'on a
laissés sur internet où l'entreprise à
qui on les a confiés s'est fait pirater
tout simplement
donc il y aura de multiples façons pour
lesquelles on se fera à pirater ces
données là partiront donc on en revient
à un petit peu au règlement européen à
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure mais
minimisons les données que l'on donne
assure assurons nous que tout ce qu'on
va donner n'ait pas d'incidences
derrière ou un minimum d'incidence sur
ce qui peut être fait lorsque ce sera
vol parce que le traverse et vous parlez
de ces entreprises qui sont piratés
peut-être qu'elles sont plus exposés que
le particulier mais le particulier aussi
sur son lieu de travail peut utiliser
son ordinateur
et donc quand on sait piratés on se fait
ou piratés aussi bien ses données
personnelles que les données
d'entreprise
donc forcément tout le monde est exposé
exhaustif message à faire passer pour
que chacun se rende bien conscience que
ce n'est pas anodin publier des
chaussures sur internet et on en vient
aux réseaux sociaux c'est la même chose
en fait lorsqu'on publie nos photos
notre vie du quotidien
c'est exactement ça l'e-réputation
demain qu'elle soit dans sa vie
professionnelle ou dans sa vie
personnelle une fois qu'on a publié faut
savoir qu il reste des traces donc quand
on est jeune c'est sympa on peut faire
des photos on peut les mettre en ligne
quand on veut intégrer certaines
entreprises aujourd'hui les justes et de
recrutement ou les drh vont l'une des
premières choses vont aller regarder les
réseaux sociaux vont regarder vont
pouvoir se faire une image de la
personne qui n'est pas celle forcément
qu'elle est aujourd'hui ou lorsqu'elle a
eu un dérapage lorsqu'elle était un
petit peu plus jeune donc faire
attention à ce genre de choses et ce
fameux droit à l'oubli sur internet
c'est la possibilité d'effacer les
données sa ronde dans le cadre de la
rgpp si on s'attarde un petit peu sur ce
ce cadre là qu'est ce qui va changer
avec ça ça doit rentrer en vigueur le 25
mai de cette année oui ça rentre le 25
mai il ya plusieurs notions alors qu'ils
sont plus effectivement des notions de
des notions de droit mais vous avez le
droit
facebook est actuellement puisqu'on peut
les citer communique énormément dessus
en disant que suite à ce qui vient de se
passer ils vont mettre en place tout un
tas de de mesures pour la traçabilité
des données pour renforcer effectivement
le le la conservation des données
or aujourd'hui tout ça était déjà
préconisé en fait par le règlement
général et c'était déjà des choses qui
devaient être mises en place
donc effectivement il ya le droit à
l'oubli a le droit de rectification il
ya le droit la portabilité
qui vont sonder droit vraiment
aujourd'hui avec des dons la cnil qui va
être l'autorité de référence sur le
fakir l'autorité de référence sur le
sujet va permettre enfin à les moyens
aujourd'hui à des moyens coercitifs
financiers
de dire à ces entreprises faites
attention il faut impérativement vous
vous sécuriser les données à caractère
personnel des citoyens si vous ne le
faites pas ben moi je voulais frais
payés voilà même si aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a quand même un discours
de bienveillance de la cnil qui dit
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui voilà fait
le nécessaire mettez en place les
processus que pour les entreprises ça
peut être lourd aussi il ya beaucoup
d'organisations il faut cartographier
les données à les données personnelles
qu'on rentre dans l'est dans les
entreprises à part où elle passe comment
ils sont stockés comme on les a sécurisé
comme on les efface combien de temps on
les garde la plupart du temps
aujourd'hui quand vous posez la question
mais les données que vous allez
récupérer combien de temps on vous les
stocker la plupart des entreprises vous
répondre happytime aeternam et ça doit
pas être le cas ce sera un nouvel outil
nouvel arsenal ça de salaire gpv pour
vous aussi
en tant qu'avocat oui naturellement
puisque encore une fois le but de ce
règlement en fait c'est de se placer
dans une logique d'anticipation et de
demander à toute entité donc pas
seulement une entreprise ça peut être
également une association bref toute
entité qui gère de la donne est donc la
donne et ça peut être une photo au
numéro de téléphone une adresse ip une
géolocalisation la vidéosurveillance
donc en fait la donne et elle est
absolument partout donc l'idée de ce
règlement consiste en fait à éduquer
nouvellement en fait j'ai envie de dire
les individus pour éviter de tomber
justement dans les dérives de facebook
avec du vol de données de tomber dans
les deux hypothèses où effectivement de
sensibilisation des gens pour qu'ils
évitent de maître par contre des photos
ou des messages sur facebook en disant
attention je suis absent de telle date à
telle date je te préviens et ne laissait
la porte ouverte à une infraction
possible de toute personne malveillante
donc l'idée à la basse et de la
sensibilisation effectivement pour que
dans cette logique d'anticipation les
mesures soient prises par les
entreprises et les entités des qui gère
de la donner pour un donc mettre en
place techniquement des process pour
éviter qu'ils aient la donne et qui
disparaissent 2 les protégés pouvoir les
modifier les rectifier sur demande de la
personne concernée les supprimer
naturellement et donc cela va induire au
niveau juridique effectivement une
modification de des contrats de tout de
tous les dispositifs qui sont mis en
place via les sites internet via les
conditions générales de vente
d'utilisation dans l'esprit de protéger
en fait la vie privée des individus
mais pour les entreprises
les entreprises important que les
grosses entreprises on imagine qu'elles
ont des services qu'elles ont des moyens
financiers pour le mettre en place c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué pour les
plus petites entreprises voire pour les
associations vous avez mentionné les
associations alors exactement c'est
toute la problématique puisqu'elle elles
prennent conscience de l'ampleur de la
tâche qui les doubles qui est technique
puisqu'il faut qu'elle vérifie tout calé
et des systèmes informatiques sécurisés
et quand bien même le système est
sécurisé souvent les voies d'entrée son
autre s'est jamais une entrée frontale
ça peut être par l'intermédiaire d'un
mobile d'une personne qui dépend de
l'association évidemment donc la logique
consiste effectivement et enfin avait
différentes pour une taille d'une f1 une
grosse entreprise pardon est une
entreprise de petite taille
néanmoins dans cette logique de
sensibilisation il ya déjà des moyens
techniques qui sont possible de mettre
en place ne serait-ce que l'hygiène
informatique donc de faire attention aux
règles de base ensuite après d'un point
de vue juridique les contraintes vont
pas non plus être les mêmes
si une entreprise à plus de 250 salariés
là des obligations qui sont beaucoup
plus importantes
on sera peut-être qu au niveau de la
justice vous avez des plus petites
structures alors il est il est à penser
espérer qu effectivement dans un premier
temps des mesures soient préconisé en
cas de contrôle pour la petite structure
et lui laisser le temps de les mettre en
place
financièrement et techniquement parlant
aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour internet c'est
la sécurisation de l'individu en fait de
sa vie personnelle de
les protéger la vie privée c'est là tout
l'enjeu si protéger celles du privé ça
c'est protéger son e-réputation son
identité numérique
aujourd'hui le monde du hack s'organise
aussi commercialement je vais juste
donner un exemple assez simple
aujourd'hui vous connaissez peut-être
pas tout ce qui rend somewhere un crypto
locker qui veut remettre en fait de deux
chiffres et les données que vous avez
sur votre pc sur votre pc et vous
demander une rançon
un beau remis il ya quelques années de
ça il fallait être assez avoir un
certain niveau en informatique pour
pouvoir le réaliser
voilà non c'est facile maintenant on
fait les logiciels qui font ça tout seul
alors mais je vais vous donner un
exemple en date qui a été relevé par
damien bancal qui est l'un de vos
confrères qui est spécialisée en
cybersécurité
qui a trouvé tout simplement une
boutique sur le dark web sur lequel vous
rend plus vous vous dites que vous avez
besoin d'un crypto le coeur vous rendez
vous remplir vous mettez votre numéro de
compte ils cognent dessus et en fait
tout simplement vous dit combien vous
voulez récupérer lorsque vous avez
crypter les données entre 0,1 et un
bitcoins et puis on vous dit gentiment
que vous ne récupérez que 90%
donc on vous demande pas d'argent on dit
juste que vous récupérez que 90 % de la
somme que vous allez rançon mais parce
que vous gardez 10 % d'accord dossard
vrai business en fait c'est un vrai
bouillon de toutes façons de la cyber
sécurité reste un vrai business
au niveau du hac donc c'est pour ça que
ça va pas ça va pas diminuer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est juste en train de
dire que n'importe qui peut devenir à
coeur avec le dark web ce qui alimente
beaucoup de fantasmes mais qui est une
réalité bien présente et auquel de plus
en plus de gens ont accès aux 6,1 mais
le dark web en soi n'est pas illégal
mais tout à fait le droit d'y aller
c'est ce qu'on va y faire
qu'il devienne légale alors parler de
piratage mais y en a pleins pleins
d'autres choses à face sur le dark web
ce serait cesser sa selle laisse de
augurer de bons jours aussi pour la
justice mais s'il ya du travail à faire
encore là exactement
merci à tous les deux détenus
participent à ce s est huit sociétés
pour résumer on vous l'avez compris elle
fait attention à vos données sur
internet la première des failles c'est
l'humain c'est ce que vous m'avez
expliqué pendant qu'ont préparé cette
émission ça reste l'humain et aucun
logiciel ne pourra combler cette faille
la merci encore à vous c'est la fin de
cette petite société a retrouvé aussi
sur notre site internet et puis on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour une
nouvelle thématique
[Musique]